obviously the TPP the trans-pacific
trade pact is not with China but it's on
the table right now the president is
pushing to try to get fast-track
authority to get the deal done
what would approval of the TPP mean for
Walmart's business well I think it's
good for the country first and foremost
we're supportive of the TPP and as it
relates to Walmart we already export
American goods and goods from other
countries into China and there's a great
demand in China for products this
particular set of agreements that don't
include China create opportunities for
us in Japan for example where we sell an
American beef in American pork I was
there not long ago and the Japanese
consumers are really responding
positively to USD approved beef and I
think that's great that's great talk to
me about e-commerce because that's where
it everybody seems to be most excited
about everybody says that if anybody can
take on amazon.com it's going to be
Walmart how do you do that well we have
to use the assets we have today our
stores our associates the technology
that we have and build new capabilities
and the way we think about it is the
competitive dimensions have been
redefined value and price are redefined
relative to how they were communicated
to customers in the past it's a more
transparent environment prices are only
going to get lower over time assortments
been broadened access to how you take
delivery of a product has changed and
the experience has changed it's not just
about how you're treated in a store but
it's also about the experience you have
on our mobile app so whether it's
digitally or through our
brick-and-mortar assets we're working
hard to serve customers you've just
rolled out this shipping pass experiment
I know it's in the very early days but
obviously it looks like a product that
could compete with Amazon Prime their
subscription service Amazon subsidizes
prime heavily they do so with fees from
third-party merchants they're willing to
eat that cost how do you think about
your appetite to eat the cost of
subsidizing shipping we've been
investing in infrastructure digitally
with our platform but also with some
fulfillment centers several of which are
going to open between now and Christmas
as those capabilities come online we'll
be able to provide customers more
alternatives as it relates to shipping
and we really just don't want customers
to have to think about
they want to shop we want to have the
broad assortment we want to have all the
services available including shipping or
picking it up in the store and that's
what this is about I take me around the
world for a second how is Walmart doing
internationally I think people forget
that if you just looked at Walmart's
international business alone that would
still be one of the biggest companies in
the world so it's hard to talk generally
but tell me what markets are thriving
where would you where do you think maybe
you need to reconsider the strategy our
businesses in Canada and Mexico or some
of our bigger businesses we've been
there for a longer period of time and
they're doing great we have a big
business in the UK and our team there is
continuing to innovate China is
important for the longer term today
we've got a little over 400 stores there
and we have a an interest in a any
commerce company in Shanghai and we're
learning how to bring digital and
physical physical together in China just
as we do here in the United States and
that's going to be really important for
us in long term we also have several
markets in Latin America so those are
important to us including five Central
American countries